cinema I think and I'm bias is the
ultimate art form like I think that it
combines a lot of the other arts writing
photography design music performance and
it puts them all together in tell the
story as a sort of primal needs to
gather out a fire and be told stories
we've had it in us for millions of years
our rebellion is all that remains to
push back the Empire
this idea of all coming together and on
the massive canvas late on the biggest
cameras you can sort of projecting a
sort of collective dream it really
affects you and the IMAX is like the
ultimate form at which to do that you
know it's the world's biggest campfire
that we're all gathering around and you
haven't really seen your film it's
you've sat down an IMAX screen and
watched it the power that we are dealing
with here is immeasurable Disney and
Lucasfilm were like okay we have to
figure out why this is different what's
unique about it and initially you don't
make a point of just putting something
odd in it just to make it different to
the sagas but we started playing around
with ideas and the thing that just crept
the surface really easily was this idea
of like slightly more realistic Star
Wars where one of the little things we
did as an experiment as we took war
photography from Vietnam and South
Pacific
the Middle East and photoshop's rebel
helmets on the soldiers and replaced
some things with stomp shoot in the
background and instead of Huey's it was
like Ewing's or x-wings and and we look
at these images and they're like really
engaging like you really thought this is
emotional and it feels real some of the
battle scenes I can't wait to see some
of that or an IMAX screen it brings it
to life in a different way and people
are making films today with that in mind
it's vital it is byte or the thing about
great movies as they need great sounds
it's one of my passions is finding the
right cinema that has the best sound
quality and the best picture quality but
the better the visuals and the sound and
the more you can enjoy the film
definitely I think it's a perfect film
to see in a place where you can
basically stop your life for two hours
and allow that huge screen to show you
this amazing world that has been
photographed beautifully what movie are
you gonna watch if you're gonna watch
IMAX of course Star War I mean look at
these an enormous of the universe of
Star Wars I don't think you're gonna be
able to do better than seeing right one
in IMAX I mean IMAX is perfectly suited
for these type of scale movies in fact
it's gonna be beautifully overwhelming
rogue one is a really immersive movie
they put you right in the middle of the
action the way it's shot it's like
you're in the middle of the battles that
all translates the IMAX format even
better we have hope
rebellions are built on hope what's
great about work one is that you
actually feel like you're there for
those two hours you are a rebel that
IMAX experience will just enhance that
are you with me
[Music]
you
[Music]
you